[Applause]
and let's take you to bristol four
people have this afternoon being cleared
of criminal damage over toppling the
statue of slave trader edward colston in
bristol and throwing it in to the
harbour they are rhian graham milo
ponsford and sage willoughby
as well as jake skews they have been
cleared today warning those flash
photography as the four appear outside
court having been found not guilty of
criminal damage they are due to say a
few words let's uh listen in to see uh
if they're about to speak
guys can we just ask you how are you how
are you feeling about the verdict we
we are and we feel ecstatic and stunned
i just i tried to write something ready
for this moment and i'm just so
overwhelmed because it never felt like
we've got we'd get here and now we're
here um
we just want to say thank you to so many
people because we have never been alone
in this journey we've been so supported
and we are you know we're such a small
part of this really
there were so many people that day so
many people like reverberating across
the world in response to it and so i
should just consult my notebook and
thanks some really key people obviously
our legal team who have been incredible
i can't thank them enough for getting us
through this
bristol defendant solidarity
bristol radical history
[Applause]
um
where we've got all of our witnesses are
like incredible witnesses who took the
oath and you know put their name on the
line to stand in court for us gloria
daniels
cleo lake lloyd russell david olashoga
julian stone
roger ball who did so much of the
research into all the history around it
um and a special mention to judah bundy
who as well who was supposed to be a
witness i didn't get to but has given me
so much hope and fire to continue with
this journey
um
all the donations to the crowdfunder
epic human beings yes all of our family
and friends who have had to enjoy this
year and a half journey with us also
um
we got everybody on the day
those 10 000 people that marched the
streets of bristol in the name of
equality foreign
exactly all the rope pullers the statue
climbers the rollers the egg throwers
the
you are marchers and the international
topplers the people that went and took
their agency and did something in their
hometown and changed the landscape of
their place because that's one thing
have been a real big lesson for me is
just being able to take agency
in my own life and the fact that we all
have ability to
say how our space is decorated and how
who we venerate and who we celebrate and
one thing that we know now is that
colston does not represent bristol
[Applause]
what do you say to obviously people who
who say you can't change history and
these monuments are part of of of
history and they shouldn't be pulled
down what was your reaction to change
history
they were whitewashing history